ciao ragazzi prima che portiate con il
video volevo dirvi che alla fine del
video c'è una piccola clip vi parlo di
una cosa che andrò a fare tra poco
quindi adesso vi lascio al video e
ricordatevi di guardare anche il pezzo
finale
bella bella senti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono famiglie e chi siamo
tornati su gps come dovrebbe fare un
essere umano indovinare dove sono qua ma
spiega c'è veramente napoli invece come
faccio a bra chi guarda era la mia
seconda scelta questa era samoa
americane va bene porca va come ci è
arrivato sto tizio qua in canoa un genio
raga con la coca cola dentro il mio
intuito mi dice che è molto più vicino
di quanto pensassi era in asia la nato
qualcuna coca cola un genio next round
le fate le porcate cadere dove dovete
contento di essere qua sto tizio o a
salve non avevo visti
tu hai una gamba sul barbecue non
sostenete accordo sembra location di
venerdì 13 questa era caduto stati uniti
mezzo al nulla
no in alaska a mio zio o italia italie
un altro finalmente perché miglia non lo
so puglia puglia puglia poi dovevo
studio suoni ostuni tanto magari con lo
sa bene anche mansioni effettivamente
alla città credo che il mio cognome
renga d'acqua in qualche mondo
io lo capisco bene il mio paese signora
mi dia una mano per favore praga vi
supplico datemi una mano si capisce
niente non lo capisco bene anche sugli
sforzo dove la via la via ha censurato
pure la via maqueda ed efficiente che
senza censura ste cose
modena raga io non ce la posso fare lo
giuro questo è chiaramente riccione far
conoscere stelvio
ma non le montagne in sicilia vite le
montagne sull'etna era sopra le ma va a
cagare
tanto se guardiamo bene riflesso si vede
la macchina che sta scattando la foto no
in 360 e la macchina e questa non è una
macchina per gelati quella e il nonno
può accompagnare solo credo sia in
sicilia però non vorrei dire cagate
quindi metto calabria non è ricca e
calabria e quella in campagna porca
vacca era in campania
venezia fermi celo celo celo celo celo
in tribuna che ce l'ho solo una cielo
qua qua qua va bene così va bene va bene
una logica più o meno lo azzeccata
almeno una peace love and ice cream
gardaland ma immagino mila mirá mirá b
gardaland non è dario resi a
mirabilandia tra l'altro però siccome
non idea di dove sia mirabilandia
mandiamo garda matricola solo dopo il
cardano non amore di una cagata invece
era mirabilandia kakà ma perché quella
sbagliata prendo ogni volta abbiamo 22
parchi a tema famosi che sono
mirabilandia garda il risveglio tutte e
due non c'è emerso umbria a foligno è
stato ha vinto i oraria mi spiace
fantastico raia fantastico il problema
adesso è che non so dove siano mbriaca
ma perché si nasconde l'umbria maledetti
e chiaro che non so dove si nasconde
foligno foligno tac non era neanche a
foligno dove chi era a gubbio però vabbè
nel gubbio metto foligno bello che se la
sua questa cioè a gubbio nel gubbio è
chiarissimo che al kubra si vede ma
senza ombra di dubbio proprio mac guest
io non capisco e sono cose che non
capisco trovo difficoltà perché c'è
darth vader li paola non so raga treni
poi siamo qua va beh è chiaro come il
suo paola prove ma come paola la crosta
marin marina di paola non era di stefano
marina ai film che posso anche muovermi
ami cioè visto a ricordare mi sono
ricordato adesso che potevo muovermi ce
la posso essere così stupido da quello
che mi fa imprecando la macchina su
sbirciare nei cartelli caserta
peccato stavolta è maledizione tac
finalmente era ora che riuscisse a
vedere milano almeno questo picco
l'angolazione pure dove che lo partito
qua per essere qua 12 meglio era l'altro
vero perché io ho 50 50 anno era p2p
vabbe dai indietro wagen transformer st
nave le ferie gilio fi e finezze che non
ci sono navi a firenze trova bene quindi
sarà libero livorno no porto santo
stefano
all'edizione roma termini 400 mentre
amado fontegrossa stazione maledizione
va dai ragazzi di fare l'ultima e poi
concludiamo perché secondo me è
abbastanza dove che siamo qua sta
facendo il suo bambino sta pisciando
sulla roccia
cosa fai sta facendo un brutto a quella
roccia lì che cosa gli ha fatto con le
rocce abbiamo a vedere se a 3
[Musica]
era in val d'aosta 6 mette motorino
azzecca un accesso all e tra l'altro è
andato mille volte dai ragazzi basta
così ho fatto anche questa volta una
figura barbina però ormai siete abituati
tutti subito anch'io però che vi sia
piaciuto raga concludo che l'episodio è
stato molto molto istruttivo quindi
ragazzi prima di concludere volevo farmi
questo annuncio che venerdì 10 novembre
alle 17 farò una bellissima cosa con
guido meda ma lascio che sia che siano
questi due bei ragazzi a spiegarvelo
ciao ragazzi è un saluto da guido media
che sono io e david j
e fa vj che lui e siamo qui per darvi un
appuntamento il 10 di novembre da allora
figlia ma l'appuntamento siamo a milano
in questo momento però noi ci vediamo a
valencia frega di milano andremo sembra
di 10 novembre perché c'è la finale va
continuato sono dico tutto la finale
della moto gp di sport quella virtuale
per averci sono i finalisti che si
sfidano tra loro è un gran premio vero e
proprio solo che è proprio sono gay coi
videogiochi quindi tu mi dai una visione
molto più motogp stica della questione è
molto più videogiochi stick videogiochi
stica della questi ragazzi e saremo una
coppia che spara migliori ragazzi si
sono ammazzati moto lui non sa niente di
videogames di spaccheremo perfetto sky
uno e sky sports mix il 10 novembre alle
17 c'è anche lui colori e di sicuro
ragazzino l'inizi si cerca dai ciao
ragazzi
[Musica]